Neuroscientist Read Montague...
...was wondering why people preferred the taste of Pepsi but Coke controlled the market.
Montague wanted to know why people would buy a product they didn't particularly like.
His data founded an entirely new field: neuromarketing,...
...the study of the brain's responses to ads and brands.
Montague looked at consumer's neural activity with an MRI machine.
Using blind tasting,...
...subjects were given both drinks with almost half saying they preferred Pepsi.
Told later which sample was Coke,...
...three-fourths said that Coke tasted better,...
...and their brain activity changed, too.
Coke lit up the part of the brain that controls higher thinking.
Montague believed that the brain was recalling images and ideas from commercials,...
...and the brand was overriding the actual quality of the product.
For years, in the face of failed brands and laughably bad ad campaigns,...
...marketers had argued that they could influence consumer's choices.
Now, there appeared to be solid neurological proof.
Daimler - Chrysler's research has recently found...
...that sportier car models activate the brain's reward centers,...
...the same areas that light up in response to alcohol and drugs.
Marketers know that some brands have a seemingly magical appeal...
...with buyers saying the brand is an extension of their personalities.
Neuromarketing research is expected to soon show exactly which products those are.
But some worry that it could eventually lead to complete corporate manipulation of consumers...
...or citizens, with governments using brain scans to create more effective propaganda.